The Dogs Aboard the Titanic
On April 15, 1912, the legendary, ill-fated
ship RMS Titanic sank.
It remains, to this day, the most famous disaster
in maritime history.
There were approximately 2,223 passengers
aboard the ship, of which 1,502 perished.
(Some sources site the figures at 2,228, with
1,503 dying.)
Besides humans, a dozen dogs were aboard the
ship on its luckless maiden voyage.
Just three survived.
How were three dogs saved in lifeboats when
there wasn’t enough room for all the human
passengers?
The three dogs that survived the Titanic disaster
were all extremely small.
The dogs were so small, it is probable that
no one even noticed them when they were carried
aboard the lifeboats.
Two of the dogs were Pomeranians, the third
was a Pekinese.
One little Pomeranian was named “Lady”
and was bought by Titanic passenger Miss Margaret
Hayes in Paris.
“Lady” shared a cabin with Miss Hayes
and was wrapped in a blanket and carried onto
a lifeboat by her when the order was given
to evacuate.
The fabulously wealthy family the Rothschilds
owned the other Pomeranian that survived.
The Pekinese was named “Sun Yat-Sen” and
was brought on board by the Harper family
(of the New York publishing firm Harpers & Row.)-
only first class passengers had dogs aboard.
One family even received an insurance payment
in the amount of $300 (about $7000 today)
for their two dogs that didn’t survive the
sinking of the ship.
Wealthy passenger William Carter was traveling
with his wife, Lucille, and two children.
Their daughter Lucy’s King Charles Spaniel
was insured for $100 and their son Billy’s
Airdale for $200.
The children begged to take the dogs when
evacuating, but Carter insisted they were
too big and assured his distraught children
that their dogs would be fine in the ship’s
kennel…
LIES!!!
When the dogs perished, the insurance company
made good on both claims.
As for the other dogs aboard, those whose
names are known include world-famous millionaire
John Jacob Astor’s Airdale, “Kitty”.
A woman named Helen Bishop brought a Fox Terrier
named “Dog”.
(How original.)
Passenger Robert Daniel brought “Gamin De
Pycombe”, his French Bulldog.
There were several other dogs aboard whose
names are not known.
Although a few of canine passengers shared
a cabin with their owners, a majority were
kept in the ship’s kennel and were cared
for by the Titanic’s crew members.
One particularly sad story involved a Great
Dane owned by 50-year-old Elizabeth Isham.
Miss Isham visited her dog at the ship’s
kennel daily.
When she was evacuating, she asked to take
the dog with her.
When she was told the dog was too large, she
refused to leave the ship without him and
got out of her lifeboat.
Several days later, the body of an elderly
woman clutching a large dog was spotted by
the recovery ship Mackay Bennet, and dinghies
were dispatched to round up the bodies of
the woman and the animal.
Eyewitness accounts and the ship’s log confirm
the sighting and recovery.
The body of the woman recovered is assumed
to be that of Miss Isham, though this was
not verified by any other means than noting
the type of dog and putting the story of her
refusal to leave the ship together with the
fact that they found a woman’s body with
the dead dog.